what is the evolutionary reason for
having consciousness I think that was
Toby who asked that God Only Knows
that's been a problem that people have
been hammering on for a long time I mean
that's the so-called zombie problem that
David Chalmers has described which is
something like how do you know that
other people aren't exactly like you
except acting in a completely determined
manner and devoid of consciousness I
don't know what the evolutionary reason
is for consciousness I mean I can
speculate like what consciousness seems
to be at least in part is a mechanism of
repair so a lot of the things that you
do are unconscious you know like when
you're driving if you're an expert
driver you're you're using your eyes to
watch the road and your eyes are moving
your hands and your arms but you're not
really thinking about what you're doing
you're not attending to it consciously
because you've built circuitry already
specialized circuitry that handles all
those tasks now what happens when you're
driving let's say that you make a
mistake well then what happens is you
consciously attend to the mistake and
you attempt to revise the part of the
automatic structure that produced the
error so imagine this imagine you're
playing the piano and you're playing a
very complicated sequence and you
stumble over part of it so you're
zooming along and you stumble over part
of it and then you attend to that you go
back and you slow down and you move your
fingers slowly and you try to reprogram
those little automatic units that have
handled that part of it you repair them
and and reprogram them and you get
faster and faster out it as they
automatize and then you go so
consciousness seems to be something that
watches what you do automatically checks
for errors and then repairs it and so
that's its function now you might ask
why a repair mechanism like that would
have to be associated with awareness and
answer that is not only do I not know I
don't think anyone knows if I was
speculating and which I've done
I think consciousness actually plays an
integral role
in being itself because I'm not
convinced that there would be any being
of any recognizable sort without a
conscious observer so I think
consciousness is actually like a center
point of the cosmos in some sense and I
think it's because of ideas like that
that the grand archetypal idea of the
soul has emerged and I think it's
correct so but how to precisely
integrate that with evolutionary theory
apart from the description that already
provided I just don't I just don't know